[Music]
thank you very much for joining us we
start in Japan where Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski has just landed in
Hiroshima later he is expected to
address leaders of the G7 who are
meeting in the city it's the latest stop
for zelenski on a global diplomatic tour
the war in Ukraine continues to dominate
discussions at the G7 Summit on Friday
the U.S agreed to support Keith's access
to advanced fighter jets and training
for its Pilots let's go live to our
diplomatic editor James base who's
covering the G7 Summit for us in
Hiroshima so James C Ukrainian president
has arrived in Japan there was some
doubts yesterday as to whether he'd be
there in person but he's there in person
a highly symbolic visit which caps a
busy diplomatic week for it
yeah very very important I think and
symbolic seeing the pictures rather
distant pictures at this stage but a
president zielinski getting off the
plane now uh in a motorcade heading into
the center of Hiroshima to join the
other leaders at the leaders hotel now
there are leaders from lots of different
countries here in addition to the G7 but
we are going to see President zielinski
I think standing shoulder to shoulder
with the seven countries of the G7
that's symbolic in itself because
remember this used to be until 2014
until President Putin took over control
of Crimea and took that Annex that from
Ukraine this used to be the G8 so you
can see this potentially and we'll have
to see exactly what pictures we see in
the coming days as president zielinski
standing in the place that used to be uh
President Putin's president zielinsky
has already as he's landed moments after
he landed put out a tweet he said Japan
G7 important meeting with partners and
Friends of Ukraine security and enhanced
cooperation for our Victory peace will
become closer today and of course this
follows his visit as you said volley to
the Arab League Summit reaching out
there to some Nations that are still
um somewhat favorable to Moscow they
haven't taken sides they've remained
neutral and you can speak to diplomats
there are certain places for example in
the Middle East what one I was remarked
on recently uh by diplomats Dubai a
place where many Rich Russians still go
so that's why I think the focus uh on on
the Arab League and of course the
financial might of the Arab League
Ukraine doesn't just need weapons it
doesn't doesn't just need political
support it needs money too yeah and and
he has the support already from the G7
leaders I mean they fully support him
but he's going to be looking at
convincing those countries that are
sitting on the fence Brazil India who
are also at The Summit in Japan
yeah absolutely from the G7 leaders
you're right he has the political
support uh he has all the right noises
and he's getting more and more in terms
of weapons and finance but things like
uh the f-16s which now the US has
decided uh that uh Ukraine can have not
from the US itself but from other
partners he's got to get the details of
that and find which NATO countries will
give him the f-16s that's I think one of
the efforts to try and actually make
that actually happen and happen very
soon that he'll be doing with G7
partners because many of those are NATO
nations with the exception of uh Japan
but as you say yes important Outreach as
well to other very big countries uh
countries like Indonesia like India like
Brazil which are major major powers in
the world and right now are not like the
G7 giving any weapons they have all
taken a position of condemning The
Invasion but they're not giving as much
and support as zielinski would like yeah
James let's talk about some of the other
things on the agenda of the summit and
China's growing nuclear Arsenal has been
discussed there tell us more about that
yeah and China will remain the other big
focus of this G7 uh this is a G7 meeting
only happens every few years but it's
happening in the Asian partner of the G7
happening in Asia China always would be
a big issue yes you're right there's a
nuclear declaration the first thing that
they put out as a statement because the
nuclear theme is a very important one
for Japan given where the Summit is
taking place in the site of the first
nuclear bombing back in 1945 but on
other issues too China is in the
spotlight we've seen the draft version
of the communique and again as we've
seen in recent years the G7 is trying to
be pretty careful here it's trying to
send clear warning red lines to China on
certain issues like nuclear at the same
time it knows that each of these seven
major economic Powers trades with China
the second biggest economic power in the
world so they want to keep that trade
open they say they're not trying to
thwart the economy progress of China but
on certain issues they say that they
need to send a message for example
excessive dependence of certain G7
countries on China in critical areas of
the supply chain it's also worth telling
you that in the draft communique you'd
expect some sort of mention of Taiwan at
the moment the wording we've seen pretty
bland just talking about the need for
continued peace in the Taiwan Straits
James thank you very much James space is
our diplomatic editor live there in
Hiroshima Japan while the growing
tension between China and Taiwan is also
on the G7 agenda Taiwanese president XI
when addressed the subject on the
anniversary of her seventh year in
office
the global consensus is very clear that
the Taiwan Strait issue needs to be
resolved peacefully war is not an option
neither party can unilaterally change
the status quo in a non-peaceful manner
while the G7 has repeatedly accused
Beijing of threats and intimidation
against Taiwan China says the group is
Prejudice Jessica Washington has been
speaking to people living in the coastal
Chinese city of Charmaine which is close
to Taiwan
this Factory in the city of xiamen there
are more than 1 000 workers and most of
them are from mainland China all except
their boss honey who is from Taiwan
he was one of the first Taiwanese
investors to come to xiamen more than 30
years ago
we are all Chinese the two sides of the
strait are also a family and we have 100
support from our compatriots here
and he says recent tensions in the
region haven't dampened his confidence
in opportunities for collaboration
we always hope that two sides can
integrate and develop and not argue over
trivial matters
Han is the type of success story Beijing
wants to highlight an example of
cross-range success but his views don't
represent the majority in Taiwan opinion
polls have repeatedly showed only a
small minority support unification in
the long or short term
these tour groups waited eagerly for
their first glimpse of Taiwan it's a
short journey of just three kilometers
from China's Shaman to taiwan's kinman
islands and you can see them just behind
me there this is about as close as we
can get traveling by boat from the
mainland
last month China carried out air and sea
drills its people's Liberation Army or
pla simulating an encirclement of Taiwan
what I expect
moving forward is uh not necessarily
risk of conflict but certainly the
potential for miscalculation for
accidents and for misunderstanding the
current situation is is quite risky in
terms of that lack of Crisis
communication mechanisms between the two
countries and the heightened activity
around Taiwan by the pla
for these Travelers the coast of xiamen
is more a holiday Hot Spot than a
geopolitical flash point but many people
come here just to see Taiwan from a
distance
I hope our motherland will be reunified
soon all Chinese people dream about it
China is developing very well and Taiwan
is not the Communist party is doing a
very good job
even the children aren't just here for
fun on the beach this group is known as
the young pioneers of the Communist
Party led by Chinese soldiers who were
teaching them about patriotism and
reinforcing the message of one China
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Sherman
China